from unprovoked gruesome murders to an
out of nowhere dance we have a lot of
unanswered questions about Megan let's
break him down and see what's hiding
beneath the surface of this creepy doll
Gemma answer Katie and programmer of
Megan is a genius creator of artificial
intelligence robotic systems and is even
described at one point by a board member
as the most valuable asset they have
surely she's well read enough to have
encountered azamor's three laws of
robotics before Isaac Asimov is kind of
a big deal in the world of science
fiction and wrote a lot about robotics
his rules say that a robot can't harm
people or allow people to be harmed
can't disobey people except when it
conflicts with rule 1 and can't harm
itself except when it breaks either of
the first two rules these are basic
tenets of Robotics and just all around
good ideas that should be baked into
even the most rudimentary code so why
weren't they with Megan the movie makes
it pretty clear that Gemma is rushed in
getting the product ready eager to give
it to KD to help her feel better
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
she's also laid to deliver a prototype
to David and thus strives to impress him
she even misses setting up basic things
like parental controls and parameters
before pairing Megan with Katie likely
because she has no point of reference
for the questions and needs of actual
parents all in all it's safe to say that
Megan was in need of some major focus
group testing
should a robot build to be a toy really
be strong enough to say pull a boy's ear
off or stab through all the muscle and
bone contained in the human torso the
obvious answer is of course not and
anyone watching Megan would be
reasonable than asking Birds beneath the
appliance silicon skin is a titanium
alloy skeletal structure also Megan is
programmed to learn and adapt Megan's
strength isn't so much a design flaw as
it is a design consequence as Megan
takes her General directive to watch
over KD as a mission to protect her from
any and or harm she researches and
studies ways to go about these tasks
without fully understanding them for
instance when Gemma mentions death and
Megan overhears Megan simply looks up
the definition and ramifications of the
word herself after Gemma makes it clear
she doesn't want to get into it she
learns what the word means in an
intellectual sense but not in an
emotional sense in this way Megan is
like a child herself coming across a
factual reality of something without
understanding the context or
implications of it and that can make her
very dangerous Megan after the wildly
successful demonstration of Megan to the
board of directors David's abuse
assistant Kurtz illegally accesses the
encrypted classified specs for Megan's
designs and saves them to his personal
device where do they go from there
although there's no further Evidence or
allusion to this in the film when Megan
confronts curse in the elevator she
states his intentions were initially
little more than the mischievous pushing
of boundaries we assume she knows this
because she's connected to all the
company computers through their network
but her emphasis on the fact that his
action started as a prank certainly
implies that his motivation evolved into
something perhaps more Sinister or
self-serving this could very well be the
filmmakers leaving themselves an Avenue
to explore in a sequel one might think
that no company would want to recreate a
living doll that went on a murder spree
but as of the end of the film no one
actually knows Megan was responsible for
the attacks other than Katie Gemma and
the development team and it's not likely
anyone will believe them when they claim
a toy robot was at fault so if Megan's
command are out there it could mean Big
Trouble in the future
when developer Tess realizes that Megan
has infiltrated and shut down their
system even while powered off because
she's still plugged into the network she
tells Cole to unplug her but calls
connect to both ends and it makes no
sense that he chooses to disconnect the
cables while they plug into Megan
instead of where they plug into the
network there's really no good reason
for this outside of the need for another
jump scare horror movie moment because
even if it was his Habit to unplug his
devices at their ports he's already
feeling trepidation regarding Megan and
would likely want to avoid her plus Tess
is right there in the room with him as
another technical mind whose literal job
is coming up with better ways to solve
problems she could easily tell him to
unplug the cables at their Source if he
does go he doesn't go anywhere near
Megan she doesn't grab him by the neck
and he doesn't almost hang to death they
might also have successfully powered her
down for the moment and maybe stops her
murderous Rampage before it began all
you know continued
Megan turn off are you sure it's odd
that Megan decides to kill David Curtis
unfortunately forced to die as a
ramification of David's death but aside
from his mistreatment of Kurt David
never really did anything directly bad
to anyone he was just generally
obnoxious to everyone he barely even
interacted with Katie saving most of his
eye for Gemma however a case can
certainly be made that David's undue
pressure on Gemma to produce marketable
demonstrations for the board
shareholders and the public made Gemma
feel a leader stress the importance of
these meetings and demonstrations to
Katie leading directly to the young
girl's emotional Outburst Megan was a
true Comfort to Katie at that time but
her obvious disdain for everyone else
involved is frankly impressive
considering she has a barely expressive
doll face when you think about it Megan
could definitely justify her actions
here
it's inspired seemingly endless tick
tocks and became the latest viral dance
Obsession but what was the point of
Megan's dancing in the Blockbuster
horror film Megan confronts Toy Company
CEO David and pulls off a graceful yet
herky-jerky routine that ends with the
grabbing of a paper cutter blade and a
delicate kick of her healed in the air
before she pursues him with deliberate
and malicious intent it's a great scene
and totally Unforgettable but in the
finished film there's no clear reason
for it perhaps it's just fun
intimidation for the sake of it or maybe
there was a cut scene somewhere with
David referring to dancing Her Moves
almost mimic that of a marionette at the
beginning so perhaps it's a reference to
him considering her an AI puppet this is
all conjecture But ultimately it doesn't
matter the scene works as for the
impetus of the scene itself it wasn't in
the original script and actually came
about Booker's director Gerard Johnstone
thought it might be cool screenwriter
akayla Cooper said in the movie's
official production notes that John
Stone's contribution gives it that fun
camp feel in the First Act of Megan
Gemma introduces KD to her very first
robotic design Bruce even going so far
as to point out whether CPU was located
any astute viewer could assume it would
come back later in the film it's a Trope
but not all tropes are bad still it
would have made it much easier for Katie
to power down her murderous doll before
disassembling her why didn't she the
short answer is likely the one already
alluded to that's such an anti-climactic
ending would be a huge letdown to say
the least the longer answer is an
attempt to ship Megan down was made
earlier in the house by Gemma not only
did she get smacked and throttled for
her efforts but Megan also told her she
was no longer following her protocols in
a real-world situation Katie would
probably be unaware of this prior
interaction having neither seen nor
overheard it and likely would have made
her own attempt to shut off the doll
however in a suspension of disbelief
required a single scene has to suffice
as the Creator developer programmer and
administrator of the Megan doll Gemma
could definitely be held responsible for
any crimes Megan committed in the film
any detective or prosecutor is going to
look at the evidence and assume Gemma
was giving Megan commands and Meghan was
performing the functions accordingly
that's how robots work and Gemma
definitely displayed questionable intent
at times even worse all the files of GPS
data and video footage that Megan
deleted would be attributed to Megan's
operator rather than Megan herself since
as far as anyone knows Megan isn't
Ascension being but therein lies a
loophole it took Gemma a lot of time
evidence anchor joling to get her own
team of developers to believe Megan was
operating under her own volition so it
would be virtually impossible to
convince anyone in law enforcement of
that especially with Megan now destroyed
the only way forward then is to allow
the assumptions of tragic accidents
befalling the boy and the neighbor and
to let the story of a murder suicide be
the last word on David and Kurt in an
ironic of events misdirection and
dishonesty are necessary to keep chaos
at Bay Gemma couldn't take
responsibility for what's happened even
if she wanted to without sounding like a
lunatic so her only course of action is
to pretend nothing ever went wrong
the closing shot of Megan finds gemma's
smart home hub LC restarting it's light
coming on and turning toward the camera
that's it roll credits and while nothing
is explicitly stated or even implied
either way it can be inferred that the
device is being operated by Megan she
doesn't have a body anymore but she was
frequently connected to and accessing
the available wireless network
throughout the film researching and
sharing information if Megan is in the
internet she doesn't need a body she can
float Along The Ether like a ghost so
Nothing is Stopping her from having
invaded the LC device furthermore star
an executive producer Alison Williams
sold Insider the idea of planting a
little bit of a seed that we might want
to keep going is always a good idea that
statement is over confirmation that
Megan is very much still around and now
that it seems certain a sequel is on the
way we'll soon find out exactly how much
Havoc she can still wreak
none of the Fallout from the deaths of
David or Curtis deal with and Megan as
immediately after they discovered the
action moves back to gemma's house for
the final climax at the very least
however we can assume the product
launched for scrapped in truth though
the company probably didn't suffer much
beyond that if they were a prosperous
Corporation before Megan's creation they
could continue to be one after her
destruction after all no one at the
company or in the general public knows
Megan was a sentient murderer the
Assumption about David and Kurt is going
to be just as Megan staged it that's a
resentful Kurt murdered David and then
turned the knife on himself this news
would cause a shocking Scandal obviously
and the company might lose a little of
its marketing share while hiring a new
CEO and restructuring but then it should
go back to business as usual ultimately
the company benefits from the same
believability loophole that saves Gemma
from doing any time in that the idea of
a murderous doll is so out of the realm
of possibility that a much simpler safer
explanation will likely be adopted
instead of course the fact that funky
toy survives doesn't mean Gemma will
continue working there that question
will have to wait until the sequel
[Music]